[MUSIC PLAYING]
YIGIT BOYAR: Today,
we are going to talk
about how to create a
modular Android application
architecture.
Obviously, the first question
we should ask ourselves
is, why do we even
want to do it?
And there's a couple of reasons.
So we'll quickly
go through them.
The first one is scale.
So if you're writing an
application with you and maybe
with your friend, it's easy.
It's not going to be too big.
Both of you can know everything
about the application.
But as your application
grows, you're
going to hire more developers.
And it will be very hard
to work on the application
without stepping on
each other's toes.
So what you can do is you can
create these modules where
people can specialize in certain
sections of the application,
and they can work independently
without swarming down others.
A similar benefit
is maintainability.
So if you have a monolithic
application like this,
where you have
all these layouts,
and when you reach to dozens
and hundreds of layouts,
it's going to be very
hard to look at it
and understand what's going on.
Instead, if you
group those layouts
based on what
feature they're in,
now it will be so much easier.
When you're looking
for something,
you will find it there.
It will never be a long
list of weird names.
And that has a new added
benefit, which is faster
incremental compilation.
So if we go back to
the previous example
where you have this monolithic
application on the left
and the modularized
application on the right,
and we change the same file
in both of these scenarios,
this is how much it's
going to invalidate.
This is how much
Gradle needs to do--
OK, check all of that
group, run more tasks.
And those tasks will
have more inputs,
and they will take
longer to run.
The smaller they are,
the faster it is.
Similarly, you can also run your
continuous integration service
faster.
So if you have an
application where
we have properly modularized--
we have a couple
of small modules,
and there are bigger
modules that depend on them.
And the application at the
end depends on all of them.
If you made a change in
this, let's say, module5,
which test do you need to run to
make sure that change is good?
The answer is very simple--
only that one and anything
else that depends on it.
This is the only
test you need to run.
You don't need to run all of
your tests because the other
modules cannot be impacted.
You might say, well, we
don't have incremental CI.
Many people are
in this situation.
And it's the same
situation for AndroidX.
So this is what we do
in AndroidX development.
We wrote a plugin that
discovers the dependency graph.
And then this plugin looks
at the Git history, figures
out which files are changed,
which modules include
those files, and then
discovers which modules
are affected by those changes.
And then it only builds the
tests for those modules.
And our test runner
runs only those tests.
You can go and check
it from this URL.
We will add it to the notes.
And you can retrofit
for your own build.
Before we did this change,
our pre-summit in AndroidX.
was taking around two hours.
After we made this
change, it now
takes from 10 to 20
minutes, depending
on what you have changed.
Last but not least, it's
also good for business.
When you modularize your
application with app bundles
and dynamic delivery-- we
will talk about that later--
you can significantly
reduce your install size.
From Play Store stats,
we know that many
of your users drop between
the time they clicked on
install to the time they
start using your application.
So the smaller your
application, the less it takes.
And you will have
just more sign-ups.
Similarly, it also lets
you test different things.
Let's say you have
an application that
has a camera feature.
And your PM comes
with this idea like, I
found this amazing library.
It's 10 megabytes, but it
takes beautiful photos.
Now, you don't need to argue
whether it's good or not.
You can implement it as
a dynamically delivered
feature, A/B test
it, see if it helps,
and then distribute it
to all of your users.
This gives you a
lot more flexibility
in trying out different
things in your application
without hurting your users.
FLORINA MUNTENENSCU:
Modules, modules, modules--
you'll be hearing a lot
this word in this talk.
So what kind of modules are we
actually talking about here?
Well, we're going to talk
about greater library
modules but also dynamic
feature modules that
are part of the Android App
Bundle packaging concept.
So let's see how we define
what we put inside a module?
How should we modularize?
So we can do this either
by feature or by layer.
So let's start with
feature modularization.
Let's see what module types
would work for features,
and also what are the
different options for packaging
that we would have, and what
are the implications of these.
So we would have a base app.
That's just an
Android application.
And then we could have a module
that's an Android library.
The app would depend
on this library.
So this means that
app would have
access to the code and
resources from module1.
But the other modules can
be dynamic feature modules.
And dynamic feature modules
can be used for on-demand code
loading via dynamic delivery.
And they would
also depend on app.
So this means that
module1 and module2
would have access to the
code and resources from app.
But then app would
declare these modules
in the build.gradle file
as dynamic feature modules.
So what's important
to remember here
is that app doesn't actually
depend on module2 or module3.
This is actually the main
restriction of the feature
modules in the app.
So even if the
app doesn't really
have access to the
code and resources,
I think this allows the option
to have the on-demand delivery
of feature modules.
So through dynamic delivery,
users can download and install
dynamic features on demand.
Modules that have
onDemand turned off
are by default added
as part of your APK,
of the one that's
downloaded or installed
on your device by the users.
And if you enable
on-demand delivery,
it means that you
as developers also
need to manage the
download of the module
from Google Play Store.
Then shared code
and resources would
be part of the core library.
And a nice benefit of
on-demand delivered modules
is that you can depend
on a third-party library
and only download it
when you're actually
downloading that module.
So this means that you're able
to decrease your APK size even
more.
OK, but how do we decide what
is a dynamic feature module
and what's not?
So for this, I'd like to look
at the 80/20 principle that
says that 80% of your users
are using 20% of your app.
So look at the other 80%, look
at those features that are not
part of your core flow
of the app, things
like expert features
or paid features
that can be downloaded later.
Similarly, you
can have a feature
like onboarding that can be
afterwards uninstalled later.
So here, the onDemand
will be false.
And then you would be able
to clean up a bit the space.
But how about something
like an About screen.
This is something
that's not part
of the core flow of the app.
Should this be on demand or not?
Should this be a
dynamic feature or not?
I think rather this is a
better candidate for an Android
library.
Because what you want is
to have an instant access
to that About screen.
It's something small.
You want to make sure that you
have a good user experience.
You don't want the
users to wait for this.
And also, I don't think it's
worth having all the trouble
that dynamic feature
modules bring for something
simple like About.
In Plaid, one of
our sample apps,
we took a different approach.
So Plaid is a news application.
It aggregates data from
three different sources--
Designer News, Dribble,
and Product Hunt.
And each of these sources
have their own presentation
and business logic.
So what we wanted to do
is to have the possibility
of on-demand delivery.
So we wanted to be able
to download these data
sources whenever we need them.
We wanted to be able
to add in the future.
others.
So this means that designernews
and dribble are dynamic feature
modules.
But then we looked at something
like search and about.
These wouldn't benefit
from on-demand delivery.
So we left these
as library modules.
Now, let's see how we
can modularize per layer.
YIGIT BOYAR: Thank you.
So one option is to
modularize your application
based on features.
Another, albeit
simpler option is
to use a layered modularization.
So what do I mean by this?
So let's look at the
Plaid application
again that Florina talked about.
Let's look at what kind
of user features we have
and what technologies
we need for them.
So we said we have
stream of news.
So we need a place
to process them.
We need API clients
to fetch them.
And we also need a UI
that shows those feeds.
Now, we have multiple
news providers,
so we need probably different
web service clients.
We want to have custom
styles because we
want to style these news
based on their source.
So we need the custom
styling library.
And we need
authentication because we
want people to be able to vote
and comment on these stories.
Which means we also need
a post UI where people
can see the details of a story
and the comments associated
with it.
So we'll take a
bottom-up approach here.
We start with the
database, using Room,
I guess, as a [INAUDIBLE].
And then, inside
this database module,
we have our entities
and data access objects.
And then we have a
web service module
on the site that depends
on Retrofit and JSON Parser
because all of the API we
use here use JSON Parser.
We can use Moshi, and it also
has data transfer objects.
We will talk about them later.
Now we may move over
to repositories.
This is where most of our
actual business logic lives in.
And now we have things like
user repository or Dribble
repository for stuff
coming from Dribble.
On top, we have our
user interfaces,
which just talk to
these repositories
to display whatever
is necessary.
Last but not least,
we said we also
need a custom styling library.
But it can be a
module just by itself
because it's not really
related to our application.
Now let's see how we can benefit
from this kind of layering.
One option is isolation.
So there's a little
crash course here.
When a module says, I
depend on another module,
it can either say "API"
or "implementation."
I know it's confusing, so I'm
going to quickly explain them.
When a module A says, I
have an API dependence
on module B, that means all
of the public functionality
provided by module B
is also provided my B.
So my dependence can access
module B's public API.
But if it says it's an
implementation detail,
then modules that depend
on A cannot see B.
They should know about B.
And this gives us some power.
So let's get to a
practical example
where we have an API that
returns us a list of comments.
Each comment has
some data inside it.
And we have a user object
about who made that comment.
Now, if you want to move
this to our database,
we want to persist it,
so we create an entity.
It's our Comment entity.
Inside that, we have an id,
we have the text and the user.
Now, if you look at this entity,
there is a little problem here
because probably we have
the same users commenting
all the time.
So it's not a very good idea
to keep that information
inside the Comment object.
Because if a user changes
their profile photo,
you need to go and
update all of them.
Another option we can do is
just create the user table.
But then we cannot do it
because our server says,
the user's inside
the Comment object.
There's a really easy solution
for this kind of problems.
We can make this a
data transfer object.
A data transfer
object is specifically
designed to get the data from
your back end to a format
that your application
can understand.
Now, we can have a separate
object for our database.
We'll call that one Comment.
And that one can
have the userid.
It'll also have a user table.
But now, why did we
do this separation?
Let's see how it
plays in practice.
So we'll go through
this scenario.
Our repository calls the web
service to get the comments.
We get the list of Comment DTOs.
Then the repository
divides these into two--
it divides them into
users and comments
and pushes them back
to the database.
Now let's look at how we
declare our dependencies now.
Our web service says, I have
an implementation dependency
on Retrofit because
the repository doesn't
need to know about that.
It doesn't matter.
Similarly, database
says, I'm using Room,
but no one else needs to know
about it Repository says,
I'm using the web services
and implementation dependency
because UI doesn't need to know
where the data is coming from.
But then here, we say,
we have an API dependency
on the database.
So in this example,
we are doing it
because it's very likely
that the same object we
are using in the
database is what we also
want to use in the UI.
Or it might be pulling
these objects as different
[INAUDIBLE] from the
database for our UI.
So we need to set it as an API
dependency now, which is fine.
But not that fine because
now our user interface
can't see the entities.
We want that.
But we don't want
our user interfaces
to have access to the database.
Because if they
access the database,
now we lost the layering
because they know
where the data is coming from.
They shouldn't, [INAUDIBLE].
Now, there's two
options you can do here.
You can be fine with this.
You know, if someone
writes a code
that makes a database query
in the UI layer, you're like,
no, no, no, you
shouldn't do this.
Or you can take this
one step further.
We could create another module
for all of our common value
objects that we use
across the application.
Some of them might be entities.
Some of them might be just
regular value objects.
And in your database
module, you can have
other entities and your DAOs.
Now, the repository
can say, I have
an API dependency on
these value objects
versus just an implementation
dependency on the database.
Once we do that, our UI only
has access to the classes
we wanted to be able to access.
So we get finer
control over them.
Another nice benefit of
this kind of modularization
is testing.
So we say we have
repositories, and we
have a user repository here.
Whoever is writing
user repository
can also create a fake
implementation of it.
A fake implementation
has the same API,
probably extends or
implements the user interface,
but provides additional
functionality.
So our user repository has
a getUser function that
returns live data for user.
The fake one has the
same functionality
but can have other
things like put this user
or put this user as an error.
These are the things you
will need when you are
trying to write your UI tests.
Once we have that
in our application,
we can make the
main UI component
dependent on the actual
implementation and the test UI
competent dependent
on the fakes.
This will make it very easy.
This is a much better approach
than trying to mock it.
Because when you
mock something, you
don't know how it is
supposed to behave.
Versus the person who is
writing the repository
knows how it will behave,
so they can create
a much better fake for you.
FLORINA MUNTENENSCU:
OK, so we looked
at how to modularize by
feature and by layer.
Feature modularization
brings you
encapsulation and
the possibility
of on-demand delivery.
Modularization by layer
brings you isolation,
allows you to isolate your
third-party dependencies
or the layers in
your app, and also
brings structure to our app.
But you can also mix and
match a feature and a layer
modularization.
But if you're starting from
a monolithic application,
we think that the
first that you could do
is to start with a
layer modularization.
And then, as time goes by, you
can go more towards a feature
modularization.
So let's see how to work
with dynamic feature modules.
Because even if this
enables on-demand delivery,
it also brings a few challenges.
So the first one
is with navigation.
So let's say that
our about feature is
inside a dynamic feature.
So from our main activity
that's part of app,
we need to navigate to
this about activity.
What we would usually do
is just launch an intent,
saying, hey, start
this about activity.
But I said that the app doesn't
have a reference to the code
from about.
So this means that you'll
get the compile error.
To overcome this,
what you can do
is just use Intent.setClassName
and pass the component name.
I know this looks a bit
strange because it's hardcoded.
And indeed, it means that when
you have to refactor your code,
you need to make
sure that you're also
updating this string.
If you're working
with fragments,
you have to do
something similar.
You would have to use
reflection to create
an instance of the Fragment.
And with fragments,
there is an extra thing
that you need to do.
You need to make sure that
you also exclude the Fragment.
names from [INAUDIBLE].
We know that this is not nice.
But at the same time,
we know that there
are no runtime
performance hits for this.
And we also want to help
improve this process
to make navigation
between feature modules
as natural as possible.
So we are working on this as
part of the Navigation Jetpack
library.
OK, let's see how we can
discover dependencies
in our app.
Let's take the
following example.
We have a search activity that
is part of the search module.
And we want to be able to
search for news in Designer News
and Dribble.
So for now, let's consider
that these two feature modules,
designernews and dribble,
are already downloaded,
so are part of your app.
But still, designernews,
dribble, and search
are three completely
different modules.
You don't have references.
You don't know how
to use, how to call,
which classes you should call.
And we also want to make sure
that in the future, if we
add another data source, we
can easily plug in that one
as well.
So we kind of want
somehow search
to depend on
designernews and dribble.
So what we do is we use the
Common Core library that
is shared between all of these.
So here, we're defining
the DataSource interface.
And then designernews
and dribble
implement that interface.
And search holds a set
of these data sources,
so it knows how
to query the data.
But things are not
that easy because when
we ought to instantiate
the DesignerNewsDataSource,
we see that it depends
on other things.
It works with the
StoriesRepository that on a row
works with the RemoteDataSource
and the LocalDataSource that
also work with Services,
SharedPreferences, maybe
even Room.
So there are a lot
of classes that you
need to instantiate
when you want
to create an instance of
DesignerNewsDataSource.
So how do we do this?
In general, what
we actually want
is to have one single
entry point for creating
the DesignerNewsDataSource.
So we would have something like
a DataSourceProvider interface
that would define the core
and getDataSource method that
would allow us to retrieve it.
And then, in
designernews, we would
implement this
DataSourceProvider
and then build the dependencies.
In search, we would
need to provide
the set of data sources.
So we would check whether
a feature is installed.
And then if it is,
we try to create
an instance via the reflection
of that data source provider.
And then we get the data
source from the provider
and add it to our
set of data sources.
Alternatively, you can also
do this via ServiceLoader.
And you can check out both
versions, the reflection
and the ServiceLoader,
in one of the samples
that we released recently.
OK, so we said
that we would need
to create the dependencies.
And chances are, a lot of you
here are also using Dagger.
So let's see how you
could do this with Dagger.
So if you're using
Dagger, you're
most likely use
another component
that you define in core.
So then, in your designernews
DatSourceProvider,
you would need to create
the graph for that component
and then from that graph to
actually get the data source.
So we said that
for the first case,
our dynamic feature modules
were already installed.
But what if they're not?
What if when we're launching
the search activity,
we only have designernews?
And we want whenever
dribble was also
installed to also start
searching for data in dribble.
So we start from the same case.
We still have a
data source that's
implemented in
designernews and dribble.
But now having just a set of
data sources is not enough.
So we also use live
data to make sure
that we're also
notifying whatever
classes are interested
in these data sources.
And then for convenience, we
wrap this inside the registry.
So Play Core gives
us the possibility
to react on modules that
have been installed.
So this means that we can
register our own listener,
and then this
listener also tells us
when a module was installed.
So this is the point where
we're getting the data source,
as we've shown previously.
And then we just add
it to the registry.
Now let's see how we
work with databases.
YIGIT BOYAR: Thank you.
So when you start
modularizing your application,
you're going to face this
problem with databases.
I'm like, where do I put them?
And there is no perfect
answer for this.
So we're going to go
through some examples
and options we can do here.
So one option is-- it's the
easier one-- you can just
have one database for all
of your application, which
is what you usually
do when you're
in monolithic application.
Or you can create
a core database
for the common
functionality and then
have separate databases
for your features.
And we also have
some plans with Room
which are not ready yet, but
I want to talk about them
because it's fun
So how do we do it if we
have just one database?
It's very easy.
So we have this database
module that depends on Room.
We put all of our entities and
all of our database objects
into that, very simple.
And then you have
modules depending on it.
Now, if you have an
architecture like this,
the nice thing is, it is
super simple to understand.
You don't need to guess
where do I put it.
You just put it there.
And then you have only
one database connection
to maintain.
And then you can just keep
it open for the duration
of your application.
Database connections
are not cheap.
So if you have multiple ones,
you need to be closing them.
And this also gives you the
possibility to share tables.
Like if you have
queries across modules,
you can easily write them in
this common shared database.
Now, the problem
with this approach
is there's absolutely no
isolation between your modules.
So description of a post
for one of the modules
might be significantly
different than the other one.
So now we need to rename
these tables to make
sure they don't conflict.
That would be hard when
you look at the code base.
And even worse.
Let's say you use the
dynamically delivered features
that Florina mentioned.
Now, even if you are delivering
the feature dynamically,
you need to put all of
its entities and data
access objects into this core
module that ships with the app.
So it creates an
awkward division
between the module
with these entities
and the rest of its code.
This is not something you want.
OK, so let's go back
to the other extreme
where we create a
database per module
to achieve the
perfect isolation.
So we have this each database.
Authentication module
has own database,
feed has own database, and
the post has own database.
If we do that, we
reach our goal.
There is perfect isolation
between all of these modules.
But now we have many
database connections
that we need to maintain.
We cannot keep it open for the
duration of the app anymore.
We need to start
tracking [INAUDIBLE],,
querying the database,
and make sure to close it
when we are not using it.
Also, if you want to write
a query that touches two
different databases,
you simply cannot.
I mean, SQLite allows you to
attach databases to each other,
but there are some
difficulties with that.
And beside that, you will find
yourself implementing SQLite
in your own [INAUDIBLE] code.
And one of the other
problems is you will end up
duplicating some data
because they will probably
have shared data, and you
will just be writing it
into both of these databases.
Of course, an obvious iteration
after looking at these two
is, why don't we just
do a hybrid approach?
To go back to this
example where we
create a database
for each module,
and you look at the feed
and the post databases,
they probably have
the same data.
You know, the feed
shows them in a list,
and the post UI shows them as
an individual one with comments.
So it is more data.
But you can basically put all
of them into one database.
Now you can share the data.
And it will be a
lot more efficient
while we can keep the
authentication just by itself.
Now, this option is
great because it gives us
full flexibility.
But the problem is
it's very flexible.
So you always find yourself, all
right, where do I put this one?
Should we merge these two or
should we keep them separate?
And you're always going
through those decision points,
and it's always a challenge
as part of your application.
Now, for Room, this is
an important problem
that we want to solve.
Similar to how we want to
solve the dynamic library
navigation in the Jetpack
Navigation component,
we want to provide support
for multimodule applications
in Room.
So this is what we want to do.
We are going to allow you
to define smaller databases
in these modules in
a way that you can
let them depend on each other.
So Room can merge
them at runtime,
while, in your code base, you
can get the isolation benefits.
And then this way, because we
know which database depends
on which other
database, we can let
you create queries in
your DAOs that query
across multiple databases.
And we want to support
on-demand delivery
so that even if your entities
and DAOs look like they're
inside the feature module,
when it gets installed,
Room will basically merge them,
depending on how you set it up.
Unfortunately, it's
not available yet.
FLORINA MUNTENENSCU: So one
thing we haven't discussed
here is whether these modules
should be Android free modules
or not.
And I think there are advantages
and disadvantages to this.
So the first thing is that
you could reuse the modules.
You could use something
like [INAUDIBLE] native
and then share that library
between multiple platforms--
between Android, iOS,
between mobile and back end.
YIGIT BOYAR: Well,
that's a great idea.
But make sure you
have that use case.
So if you start like, oh,
let me remove all the Android
from this code base, so maybe
three years in the future,
we're going to have
cross-platform,
how do you even
know that code is
going to survive three years?
So don't do it if you
don't have the use case.
FLORINA MUNTENENSCU:
Having Android free modules
means that for that
module, we just
need to implement a unit test.
That's all.
We don't need to implement this
Android instrumentation test.
That can be quite slow.
YIGIT BOYAR: It's
true, I don't disagree.
But writing an
Android application
that doesn't use the Android
framework is a challenge.
You'll find yourself
duplicating things
or start mocking
things in your tests.
So if you're doing it just for
the testing benefits, don't.
Just use Robolectric, and you
can get the same speed benefits
without trying to reinvent the
Android framework yourself.
FLORINA MUNTENENSCU:
Then in general,
when you read about the
architecture and the theory
around architecture and clean
architecture, one of the things
that you'll see, one
of the guidelines
is that you should minimize
dependencies to make sure
that you're not depending on
classes that you're not using.
This also means that
you're able to do
a clear separation of
concerns, making sure
that your business logic doesn't
depend on any UI classes,
for example.
It allows you to build
better abstractions.
YIGIT BOYAR: Abstractions
are great, I agree.
But you need to be careful.
Just like as you add more
and more abstractions,
your code base will get
more and more complicated.
So as you add these
abstractions, always
think about it like, what
benefit am I gaining from this?
So the TLDR off this talk is,
you go back home after I/O
and start rewriting your
application in modules.
[LAUGHTER]
No, we're not done yet.
So it's someone responsible
in the Android team
to show you these options.
But it's your responsibility
to learn them, investigate,
see if they work
for your use case,
and then decide
for your use case.
These are options.
These are not rules.
There is no perfect solution
that someone figured out.
It depends.
And also, when you're
doing this kind of changes,
you should always compare
your short-term costs
with your long-term benefits
and make a proper decision.
Speaking of cost and
benefit, the modularization
or this abstraction graph
usually looks like this.
So, once you start doing
some modularization, maybe
the layered one, which
is like super easy to do,
you're going to get a
lot of benefits out of it
without spending too
much time doing it.
But then, if your
project grows, maybe you
can start looking at
modularizing by features,
spend more time on
those kinds of things
because you need
to scale the team.
But then, if you're in the world
of Googles Facebooks, evils
of the world, then we spend
a lot of time on these things
because we have hundreds
of engineers trying
to work on the same code base.
So it's OK for us
to spend this time.
So if you're in a
similar situation,
yes, go as far as you
can go because you're
going to gain something.
But if you're not in that
world, don't try to do it.
Because will your users
say, oh, this application
is very well architected?
No, no one will ever put that
five-star comment saying that.
They're going to say things
like, this is very sleek,
it's very robust.
Or this application has
great features, I love it.
So all of these things
we're talking about
are a means to an end.
We want to have happy customers
and want to have more of them.
So when you make your
architectural modularization
decisions, always keep
your customers and users
in your mind.
Thank you.
FLORINA MUNTENENSCU: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]